this is going to be like the ultimate
goal because once you solve it there
it's easier to scale it up and to
deliver better performance so if you do
it on the system level it's similar it's
like you know it's not
curing
the the the issues and problems just put
like some you know and
give like just a medicine but you're not
curing the
the the main issue or the call
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillary stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders and welcome
michael biton the ceo and co-founder of
edionix dr michelle biton adionix's
co-founder and ceo is a pioneer
entrepreneur and a material scientist he
is one of the only experts in future
energy research he did his phd in
materials science and postdoctoral
research at imperial college he founded
edionix with two of his professors from
imperial college in 2017.
in addition to the business side he has
volunteered over the years as a co-chair
and as a board member at the israeli
business club london
albiton welcome to 20 minute leaders how
are you
very good thank you very much for having
me
i'm excited to dive deep into the world
of rechargeable batteries renewable
energy and and what you're doing today
with edionix both your own personal
journey talking about adionix and
then a little bit more broadly about the
vertical and the domain the different
challenges that are being presented
today and where we're at as we're
approaching the end of 2021 and with
this world obviously rechargeable
batteries
is becoming an increasingly relevant
problem to be solved across the board
and and we're seeing a lot of different
players that are that are thinking about
this a lot of different world experts
that are talking about this is one of
the main challenges that we need to be
solving right now to to take our or to
take humanity forward and so michelle
let's start off tell me a little bit
about yourself and how do you find
yourself
enter the world of rechargeable
batteries
yeah first i think this is the the best
timing in the in the history to be a
part of the battery domain
and it wasn't like that when i actually
joined to the battery domain almost 10
years ago it wasn't sexy as today it was
important but not as sexy as today
and we have to say that thanks to to
tesla of bringing this topic into our i
would say
everyone understand what is batteries
today electric vehicles and it wasn't
like that before
and and i'm material scientist by
background uh from bengal university in
israel first degree master's degree
mostly focused on semiconductors and
then i had an opportunity to move to to
london to the uk
for a phd in the field of batteries
and the research was to better
understand how the battery structure is
going to affect the battery performance
and battery properties and this is
i would say increase the interest into
the topic
i went to almost all the biggest
conferences in the world and i came few
times to the my phd supervisor at that
time and asked them about like some
crazy ideas you know like very
uh
every israeli
and trying to to save the world and to
build his own company and i
yeah
a few times i came with few ideas and
always they said no it's not going to
work it's against the physics against
the thermodynamics it's not going to be
commercially available and with the the
idea of adionix actually they gave me a
green light they said it's scarce it's
it's positive
and then i said
you know what i got
you worked for me for the company and
they started to laugh and fast forward
their full time at adionics and that was
the biggest achievement that time of
course since
we have more achievement
i love it i love it okay adionix what is
it about
so today most of the focus on on the
battery and
research uh company startup giants are
trying to improve the chemistry of the
battery this is across all the border we
hear lots of
uh i would say buzzwords of new
batteries and new chemistries
and we are taking the undeveloped
untapped concept in the battery the
battery architecture one component
inside the electrodes called current
collector
the current collector it's a 2d metal
foil similar to the foil that you have
in your kitchen
and believe it or not it hasn't changed
in the last 30 years
everyone even tesla using the same colon
collector that invented back then the
same kitchen for
and
many tries to to replace it or suggested
waves how to improve performance
via replacing this component
but no any solution managed to
be at scale or at commercialization i
would say in every sector in every
domain and the reason for that that no
one managed to solve the manufacturing
to date
so how to build those structure in a
cost effective way that will be battery
graded
and can work in different chemistry
simultaneously and that was our goal
from day one we knew there is like a big
potential a huge potential of moving to
novel structure to smart structure not
to use this down to the
structure but
we need to build millions of cells a day
at competitive cost and of course they
need to be safe and with improved
performance otherwise there is no only
justification to build something new
and that's how we started
and the idea is to combine the
manufacturing process non-manufacturing
process using ai
and sophisticated algorithms to combine
them together as the idea of adionix is
also to
digitalize the process of improving
batteries
i love it okay so take me one step back
and
let's talk a little bit more broadly
about why this is a problem that is
relevant for today you mentioned this is
the best time in in the history of
batteries to to be to be working on
these types of problems but how how is
power
the advancement of batteries and the
advancement of new chemistries and and
new production mechanisms how is that
going to impact our daily lives you know
in in the most both trivial and
non-trivial ways
yes so batteries are everywhere like
from mobile phones i'm speaking now from
the airport so they need to walk on
batteries their laptops
devices that need to be
without any wires that need to be mobile
electric vehicles of course energy
storage so there is no any device and
that we can think about it that battery
won't be i would say can be part could
be part of of operating this device
and from even marine application
aviation space
so it's becoming broad
and we've mentioned already tesla so
tesla managed to push
and to um bring the electric vehicles
into the market and even to car makers
to to change like it it's a paradigm
shift in terms of how to tingle so they
are not just making
electric vehicles they are energy
company utility company what they are
going to offer and this is something
that most of the or most of the car
maker is starting to understand some of
them even applying that volkswagen
building six gigafactories around the
world
and this is
also from few different reasons
one reason is to be responsible for
the the future of their
ability to manufacture
to make sure there is enough batteries
to supply the demand
and also to be the owner of the
performance and from the economic point
of view battery
in in vehicles batteries up to 40 of the
cost of the vehicle and that was the
driving force to um reduce the price
when you reduce the price the cost of
batteries uh below certain amount you
make it
competitive compared to internal
combustion engine to conventional cars
so cost is i think the the main driving
force to
convince the public to move to electric
vehicles and all the other of course are
important but the main driving forces
cost
and this revolution and i would say push
other application let's say energy
storage when we know how to
generate renewable energy from sun wind
but the sun is not always shining the
wind is not always blowing and we need
to store the energy
and today uh
the best vehicle to store energy is
batteries especially if you're talking
about residential uh i would say storage
a our we have like solar panels we can
store the energy
and
do that in very efficient way so it's
across all the border and we are going
to face it more and more in the future
if the battery cost it's going to be
down and then there is more motivation
to replace and i would say other
um
other applications that require
batteries
now in general if we're looking at the
battery space and the space that you're
in is this say
you know what type of market is this is
this a winner take all market could
there be multiple multiple large players
in the field working simultaneously is
it you know big contracts that you're
getting with the oems or or different or
different service providers what what is
sort of the trajectory of a traditional
you know
rechargeable battery company today
so today there are i would say giant
companies that building batteries
probably we know panasonic samsung lg
sk catl most of them are
from asia and but we we see
more
a companies that are in the west
the north vault in sweden and other
companies that now
are building but the the knowledge you
know on it definitely is coming from
japan china mainly china and and
korea south korea and in china seventy
percent of the lithium-ion batteries
today produced in china are related to
china from supply chain or production
and
and for a starter battery startup it was
a
two choices either to build your own
battery factory or to be
sold to battery factory and it's very
capital
i would say intensive to a build your
own factory
and the development are very long
similar to pharmaceutical industry
and
cycles are very long
and today
the need is huge and then it's like more
possibilities for new players to to come
and there are new factories so they can
adapt and i would say they have to
be more innovative otherwise they will
not be able to compete with a giant
factory so they need to adopt new
technologies so that's why there is a
very good timing to be active and also
the public opinion and we see
uh for instance with biden's
administration how much fund is
i would say dedicate to to the energy
domain so it's becoming more and more
interesting to be active in the domain
during this time
interesting and so if as as the leader
of this company and as you're pushing it
forward what are the biggest challenges
that are perhaps different from those of
traditional tech startups that you're
facing or that you're expecting to be
facing
in the coming years as you're building
this out
yeah so traditionally it's very
conservative
industry
and
also improvement of batteries with
incremental i would say innovation
two percent every year you don't see
like a nature or a leapfrog
over
the years or it's not the same pace of
semiconductors which move low
etc
and now
there is a big change big change because
as i mentioned like tesla becoming also
battery producer and other car companies
thinking about like to
offer energy solution not only
vehicles
and then the the broader is becoming
more and i would say um um
something that is not i would say very
sharp
and then you need to choose who is going
to be your
a client
and who are the clients and how to work
with few clients together simultaneously
because today okay
we are you need
to um
ask the end user what they are looking
for but at the end you need to build
your batteries with battery
manufacturers so to deal with few
parties simultaneously it's a it's a
challenge but i think that the industry
is moving so fast so they also um
trying to adapt into a new solution and
a
new um technologies
and so how much of the innovation right
now lies in the actual chemistry of the
of what of what comprises of the battery
versus the manufacturing mechanisms the
ability to scale and to do it in a in a
cheap way obviously those things are
interconnected but but what is really
the driving force of the innovation
right now
yes i'd say
traditionally it mostly was the
chemistry the focus on chemistry from
government research centers
and giant companies and startups
in the last five ten years we see a
major
movement into
engineering and the system level
so automation and
gigafactory stair factory scaling up
lots of robots that control so less
manpower of course it's also one of the
driving force for cost reduction
and this is mostly on on a scale level
and with electric vehicles we see lots
of also innovation on the system level
pack level battery management system
cooling system
and i think the the missing part in the
puzzle is fundamentally to look on the i
would say basic structure
the the unit that is repeated in every
system
and in every cell you have many
electrodes in every
i would say a cow you have thousands of
cells
so if you look fundamentally on the
very basic repeated unit
and then trying to solve
a fundamental issues there
and
e-dissipation turmoil like to have like
even temperature there to improve the
mechanical stability to have more
surfacer
very aspects that important there and to
link it also with software modeling
and this is going to be like the
ultimate goal because once you solve it
there it's easier to scale it up and to
deliver better performance so if you do
it on the system level it similar it's
like you know it's not
curing
the the the issues and problems just put
like some you know
give like just a medicine but you're not
curing the the the main issue or the
call
and we are trying to build it from the
foundations from the
building blocks that creating these
systems
wonderful take me back a little bit back
to your journey and your entrance into
this world
how early did you realize that this is
what you want to be working on
or this field is something that you want
to be working on
[Music]
yeah so i wanted to and do something
related to science even since since
school and engineering mainly
and as every israeli i served in the
army and i was in a combat unit and
after the army i went to south america
and i remember that my mom
even registered me to the university
so she introduced me to different
engineering
and
departments
and then i went back and i used to walk
in a factory in the south of israel in
the dead sea
and
i
haven't like no idea about like
different engineering like what is does
it mean in reality but once i had this
like work experience i understand what i
don't want to do
and then it's kind of eliminate the
options and i really like science and
also engineering and i found that
material science and engineering it's a
combination of both
and in the first year it was i would say
lots of math physics but then it's
becoming more and more interesting i
started to love the topic and then at
that time
i was
my my
master's supervisor convinced me to to
move to
to do like
a masters a degree
and to continue working small mostly
nanotechnology
and i went to i managed to get into the
battery domain by chance really by
chance lucky he was trying to um
convince me to continue for a phd
in his department i felt a bit bad to
say no because it was my academic father
and i really liked him and i said you
know it would be boring if i will
continue and i will do all degrees in
the same university
if to do like a phd i would do it abroad
and i just throw something to the air
and when i started imperial everyone
asked me for how many universities did
you apply and i was sorry to say that i
applied only once
and i didn't i wasn't looking for like
specific topic or university it was just
you know sounds very
uh
attractive to move to london to get like
a very impressive like scholarship to
live in south kensington
and to study there so and and to enjoy
london life and this is what i did
and
while starting and entering into the
battery domain and even after three
years i said i don't know anything about
it like
but you know just after that all
the the knowledge all the uh
and i would say
a time that i spend
in that field manage me to understand
okay now i know and i can do something
in this domain
and the ability to start a company it's
thanks to today my co-founders smart
partners they are bringing all the the
knowledge and the background
understanding
and at the beginning i was just a
delivery boy
and i i knew about science but i told
them guys
no worries i will make sure that we are
going to bring funding and to build the
company
and i for offer them first like better
future and even better and i would say
condition in terms of consumption
consumption from the university yeah
i love it i i think that's just so so
cool and obviously throughout this
conversation i can easily pick up on on
the inspiration that you derive from
your work and i love this integration of
academia and business and
understanding the the positive impact
that you're going to have and the scale
that you can achieve what are two three
or four words that you would choose to
describe yourself
a
friendly and
dedicated
and ambitious
thank you very very much best of luck
with adionix i can't wait to be driving
in cars with with your battery there and
and seeing where things end up and and
good luck on your journey i think it's
just really really cool thank you thank
you very much mike it was a great
pleasure of course
you